I loved this movie I mean I'm a little
biased because I am Latino but it was a
really really cute movie so sweet I mean
Freddy why was this holiday rom-com uh
the movie to get you back into the genre
we missed you a little bit Yeah I
appreciate you missing me
um it was three things one my daughter
is starting to have an interest in
acting and so my wife and I both kind of
said okay we want to be examples for
that my son could care less he just
wants to race cars and go fast and punch
people not the last part but uh but so
that was the the one part of it I have
no idea how your tears are going to
react
Welcome to our home
what's this oh that's that's nothing
this is just the verse where's the hook
well I'm still working on it
I could help you with this well
what the main thing was I don't get to
play Latinos very often in this business
unless I create and write the show right
um otherwise it's always an after the
fact Studio thing where the character's
name is Mike Smith and then they cast me
and they're like it's Mike Ramirez and
all of a sudden they're like look we
hired diverse people normally and it's
you know it's an afterthought so that I
don't count any of those so when I do
get an opportunity
to earn the respect of a director and
and writer and and producer that are all
sort of in this world and there's not a
lot of Latinos that at that level that
can get movies made a lot of them are
just trying to to get in a position
where they can assist one another sure
I've met a lot of resistance over the
last 20 years so when I get that
opportunity I promise I'm ready because
I've been ready for 23 years man no
absolutely in fact Amy let's kind of uh
piggyback off that because the the
diversity is there but the
representation was also behind the
camera too talk about how important that
was to this whole story in this
experience definitely that's what I
think makes this project trailblazing
it's already rare to find a classic
Christmas American film made here with
a Latino family but it's very rare to
have it written by Latinos and it's very
exciting because we really had a
phenomenal team and we have Latinos
behind the camera and headlining the
movie so come on really nice to have
this all-star cast of of teammates
coming together and it's really nice
like you said to have the authentic
voice of tamales that aren't just like
oh maybe some tamales in there Freddie
your daughter in the film her Christmas
wishes to meet her favorite pop star of
all time my Christmas birthday wishes to
one day meet Angelina let's go Grant her
Christmas wish your kids are 13 and 10.
who's that pop star for them that if you
surprise them on Christmas morning they
would just flip okay my daughter loves
girl in red oh it was opening for Taylor
Swift I'll call in this tour so instead
of playing at like 10 000 seat theaters
she's gonna have 60 000 people getting
even though this girl's music I think
she's from Finland okay oh that's why
you've done he's got taste oh yeah she
likes uh she likes Taylor Swift too she
she has a kid we I still buy records so
she has all these on anyone that cuts a
vinyl she has it now and has an old
school record player so she has a Katy
Perry record I would probably say those
are the top three and she's getting a
lot into like more alt Rock now like
Heim and groups like that so so yeah
she's uh that's mainly what I listen to
is all runs I love it and my son he
doesn't care
you know what's so funny this movie is
all about falling in love while working
together and Freddie we just talked to
your wife of 20 years which is amazing
and she says she's forever indebted to I
know you did last summer because that's
where you all met
you got a minute
[Music]
I gotta get back to work
call me is that where you all fell in
love no we were just friends man I
didn't I didn't think she ate enough so
I made sure I I cooked for her and she
didn't have a driver's license so I was
her chauffeur and I would drive her to
the gym every day and then go to the
store or go to the you know go get
myself some lunch and then drive her
back and we would just have it was an
hour drive we shot shot in this tiny
little crazy town called Southport that
did not want us there and I would drive
her to Wilmington every every day that
we had off every day during rehearsals
and so we would have you know 55 minutes
if I drove the speed limit to kind of
like get to know one another and she was
from New York City
Manhattan and I am not I am a SoCal kid
so we were night and day and it was just
our philosophies on life never clicked
and then one day everything clicked and
it was about probably three years later
and we started dating and she's been my
girlfriend ever since
[Music]